de lo que vamos a platicar en este vídeo
es de las desventajas del sistema
bancario de reserva fraccionaria las
desventajas la primera y más grande
bueno todos están relacionadas entre sí
pero la primera y más grande es que es
inestable a menos claro que tengas un
montón de ingeniería financiera por
parte del banco central y del gobierno
para estabilizarlo pero usualmente son
soluciones antinaturales que traen otro
tipo de problema pero va la razón por la
cual digo que es inestable es porque
pues mira todos estos depósitos de aquí
pues se prometió que se regresaría en
verdad que el dinero estaba seguro y
entonces que los clientes en cualquier
momento podían venir y exigir su dinero
en teoría el dinero estaba a la vista
pero en práctica eso no es cierto casi
todo está prestado y entonces no se
puede ser que estos dos bancos sean
buenos que inviertan bien pero este de
acá puede estar haciendo cosas oscuras
digamos que presta su dinero de una
forma muy mala no se lo regresan o peor
aún a lo mejor es algún tipo de fraude
donde los ejecutivos están quemando
dinero o lo que sea esto sí acá son
buenos actores pero estoy acá es un mal
actor hizo un error y entonces de
repente este dinero desaparece ahora si
no tienes ningún apoyo por parte del
banco central o del gobierno entonces
todos estos clientes van a decir escuché
que algo oscuro sucedió en este banco
van a venir se van a presentar en
ventanilla verdad todos al mismo tiempo
y van a decir hey regresando a nuestro
dinero y entonces va a ser muy claro que
su dinero no está ahí que su dinero fue
prestado que un poco se perdió y bueno
entonces pues va a haber un montón de
problemas verdad van a estar enojados
vas a estar enojados y tristes y esto no
sólo es malo para este banco o vaya
incluso consideremos una situación en la
cual el banco no tiene la culpa en
realidad puede ser que se haya creado
pues un rumor digamos que comienza un
rumor de que este banco está haciendo
algo oscuro entonces pues puedes
imaginar que todos los clientes se van a
aparecer en ventanilla y van a pedir su
dinero entonces el banco va a decir ok
te doy el 10% el resto no lo tengo
porque que crees lo preste los clientes
se van a enojar pero esto no sólo va a
afectar a este banco porque cuando estas
personas no puedan obtener su dinero
entonces todo el sistema financiero
todas las otras personas que tienen
dinero en otro banco van a decir hey el
sistema bancario no está tan padre como
yo creía entonces pues para estos bancos
también va a haber problemas verdad
vamos con hicieron cosas oscuras pero
sus clientes también van a aparecer van
a ir a ventanillas van a pedir su dinero
de regreso porque estaba a la vista
verdad y por supuesto no lo van a poder
obtener porque el banco lo tiene
prestado esta es una situación súper
mala y se conoce como retiro masivo
consiste justo en eso que los clientes
vayan al banco pidan todo su dinero y el
banco no se los pueda regresar un retiro
masivo es una situación muy muy muy mala
para la economía porque pues porque
puede hacer que los bancos más
importantes quiebren que ya no haya
préstamos que se congele el crédito pues
entonces pues esto va a ser una crisis
total para el sistema financiero va a
ser que se caiga totalmente y que hagan
una digamos espiral horrible hacia abajo
bueno la forma en la cual el gobierno
suele enfrentar este problema de los
retiros masivos
es creando un seguro para bancos el
mecanismo varía un poco según el país
pero en méxico tenemos el ipab o sea el
instituto de protección al ahorro
bancario esto en méxico quiere decir
básicamente que tu depósito está
asegurado contra cualquier pérdida así
el banco está protegido por cierta
cantidad de pérdidas de modo que si
alguna de estas situaciones sucede y el
banco pues no tiene el dinero a la mano
para pagar entonces el ipap se hace
cargo y dice sabes que nos vamos a
asegurar que todos los clientes obtengan
su dinero de vuelta por supuesto este es
un proceso largo aburrido y bien
burocrático pero al final de cuentas
puedes obtener tu dinero de regreso sin
embargo eso pues crea otro problema más
vamos al problema número 2 que es un mal
incentivo mal incentivo o bien digamos
que pues como lo diremos indisciplina
mercantil porque porque ven en un
sistema tradicional si yo le doy mi
dinero a alguien y sé que ese alguien se
lo va a prestar a alguien más a mí me
debe importar muchísimo cómo prestar su
dinero me gustaría ver cómo administra
su negocio y por supuesto me gustaría
muchísima transparencia en términos de
qué inversiones se están haciendo y qué
tan seguras son pero en una situación en
la cual todos los bancos están
asegurados por el ipab pues
esencialmente el gobierno está diciendo
yo te respaldo y entonces de repente a
los clientes ya no les importa tanto qué
hace el banco con el dinero porque claro
tiene un seguro del ipab y así se
empiezan a fijar en cosas más
superficiales como el color de la
tarjeta de crédito o que haya muchos
cajeros o que tenga un buen servicio de
internet los clientes se preocupan por
esas cosas ya no se meten en las
finanzas y entonces ya no tenemos ese
incentivo de mercado para que los bancos
digan mira estamos siendo buenos
pastores de tu dinero manejamos muy bien
nuestro activo y pues vamos a dejar que
todo el mercado nos analice verdad
entonces se pierde ese incentivo el
tercer problema déjame escribirlo por
acá con el sistema de reserva
fraccionaria es que la reserva
fraccionaria le da al banco a la banca
privada mucho control de la oferta de
dinero si prestan más entonces déjalo
como aquí el préstamo se traduce en
dinero en más oferta de dinero también
se vale al revés verdad si no hay
préstamo entonces eso quiero decir que
va a haber una contracción del dinero en
la oferta el problema con eso es que si
tenemos una decisión por ejemplo si la
economía está débil
y si hay una recesión entonces una
política monetaria estándar recomendaría
aumentar la oferta de dinero o sea se
podría bajar la tasa de interés para que
la gente pida más préstamos y entonces
no se gaste o invierta entonces durante
una recesión queremos más dinero
entonces qué va a suceder pues el banco
central si puede hacer eso verdad el
banco central pues puede imprimir más
dinero y puede ya sabes pues comprar
comprar valores y todo eso pero con la
reserva fraccionaria eso solo es parte
de la oferta de dinero también tenemos
que considerar el préstamo y durante una
recesión pues el préstamo disminuye
déjame ponerle que queremos y que
tenemos el banco central quiere más
dinero pero la realidad es que una
recesión causa que los bancos se
espanten que sus préstamos no sean
buenos y tengamos menos préstamos lo
cual se traduce esencialmente en lo
opuesto que queremos en menos dejarle
pongo entre comillas dinero porque
depende de la definición de dinero pero
se traduce en menos dinero en
circulación
ahora también sucede lo opuesto en un
boom o sea cuando la helada con nuestra
débil en una recesión se hace peor
porque hay menos préstamos y hay menos
dinero entonces es mucho más difícil
para la gente tener acceso al capital
pero también pasa lo opuesto en un boom
déjame acá arriba para tener más espacio
en un boom cuando la economía está así
super bien tal vez no sea mejor se está
sobrecalentando el banco central va a
decir ahí deja mente sacar un poquito de
leña de la hoguera entonces lo que
quiere el banco es que haya menos dinero
menos dinero verdad el banco central
puede hacer eso ya sabes comprando valor
es verdad no perdón vendiendo valores
obtenido el dinero y eliminando lo
entonces si el banco quiere que haya
menos dinero en circulación pues si
tiene un poquito de influencia sobre
ello sin embargo también hay que
considerar el préstamo en un boom los
bancos sobre confían y empiezan a
prestar demasiado más préstamos a su vez
ese incremento de préstamos se traduce
en que tengamos más dinero eso sería
echarle más leña a la hoguera eso puede
sobrecalentar la economía y causar
problemas tipo inflación entonces en
muchas ocasiones lo que causa este
sistema de reserva es que la oferta de
dinero vaya en dirección totalmente
opuesta a la que se espera incluso
cuando el banco central tiene ciertas
políticas monetarias al respecto